the fires are marching consuming homes
cars entire towns in their path
this is unprecedented the scale of
destruction
just simply hard to comprehend almost
half a million people in oregon have
been ordered to evacuate
and the residents of its largest city
portland
have been told to get ready to get out
not everyone is listening
i've been driving up and down the road
the whole time
with the flames on one side of me
i don't know i've been through it i've
lived here 37 years so this isn't the
first one i've been through
you know as long as the roads are open
you can drive right through
you know you just can't be afraid of the
fire on either side of you
your car might end up blistered if you
get too close
an untold number have died trying to
escape too late
and officials say the death toll will
rise
as of now there are early reports from
from our state police
that there are dozens of missing persons
related to the fires
the fires are so massive this is the
view from 1.5 million kilometers away
this is the air that tens of millions of
americans are breathing
and doctors worry that could impact the
fight against the coronavirus
these uh particles in the air the
pollution
it weakens the lungs defenses because
it irritates our lungs we have increased
secretions in our lungs in our upper
airways
it can make it easier to get ill from a
virus or other type of infection
these fires are historic and state
leaders say it's only going to get worse
because of climate change this is not an
act of god
this is not something that happened
because of evolution or meteorological
conditions
that would have been here without
without our industrial base
this has happened because we have
changed the climate of the state of
washington
in dramatic ways western wildfires
happen
every year but not like this
in the past they are usually only
brought under full control when the
rainy season begins
that isn't expected to happen for weeks
or maybe
even months patti culhane al jazeera